you just got back seeing some new rocket
League updates coming later this summer
what are they all about first we set off
I'm very sorry to all my co-workers that
I just had a lot of fun because it
didn't feel like work at all okay so
yeah I like rocket League a ton in these
two new modes are gonna fundamentally
change like how you engage with the game
like all the modes that we've seen in
the past that they introduced one of
them is if you remember the the mode
where you got to use items you get like
the boxing glove and the spikes for
example well there's this new mode loops
called spy trap and the whole idea is
that every car has spikes all the time
when they have the ball which is like
the moment they touch it it sticks to
the spikes and it sticks anywhere in
their car where touch it doesn't just
like move to the top they can then be
destroyed with just a single touch it
doesn't have to be like a high speed ram
so it kind of creates this like rugby
type scenario where it's it's very
volatile and you know when you get
touched use a ball your car explodes so
there's like boom boom cars exploding
all the time but you can only explode if
you have the ball someone hits you you
can't just like you can't hit anymore
like that but yeah and it's just you
know the goals have also been removed
out from the walls so once again those
are those are there you can drive behind
them and there's like a ramp going above
it so if you're really good you can like
drive up with it attached to your car
like do a flip and then in those
scenarios where maybe you can't drive
the ball in but you want to move it you
can release the spikes only when you
have the ball and that'll like let it go
it's a very subtle move right because
you're not like hitting the ball with
your car unless you can let it go mid
flip while doing the flip and then
connect on the other end but okay
there's a ton of depth there's a ton of
room for mastery here and playing the
dads I caught a glimpse of that you know
jumping off walls doing flips and like
letting it go in the air so then it
flies and even when their car wouldn't
make it it's super fun it's it's it's
really challenging and then they move
this over to a different mode where we
were effectively playing on a giant
court with the beach ball as the ball
the physics are way different than the
regular rocket League ball it's very
floaty I imagine I'm super floating
right and it's like when you hit it
because it has less mass it doesn't just
like fly as fast as you'd think so even
if you hit it going fast it's so kind of
like like floats in the air to get where
it's going which it just totally changes
like how you think about scoring a goal
like you want to be gentle about it you
don't want to be super forceful or else
you might cause it to
you know just screw up and won't do what
you expect it's not as like off-the-wall
rocket league joke sign is off the wall
as the as the spite trap mode but you
know it's fun in a different way I think
one of my favorite parts about it is the
fact that depending on how you hit the
ball just like in regular rocket League
it can spin but because of again like
the lack of mass that it has it the air
physics sort of like impacted more so
the ball will really kind of curve not
traumatically so but enough that you
really have to think twice before just
hitting the ball because it's really
hard to calculate where it's going it's
like you have to develop a new sort of
muscle memory and instinct when when
playing are both these modes limited
time runs like are the only last thing
for a supposedly this summer I believe
so there's a chance that could be wrong
about that I know at least one of them
is gonna be replacing the current mode
when it comes out in July I believe that
is this bike track one and yeah but I
think also they are adding like
permanent items for the collection is
gonna be like you know eighties cars
like KITT from Knight Rider you also
have the station wagon from ghostbusters
but yeah it's a you know there's also
like toppers you can get like an 80 cell
phone and a cassette or like a VCR which
is there's all well and good but yeah
it's just another batch of like fun
updates for rocket League and I'll tell
you what I was a little tired today but
this flight totally worth it and those
are the updates coming to rocket league
this summer for more III coverage stay
tuned game spot
[Music]